la violence fait partie intégrante de la
vie rurale
j'ai appris à recoudre une plaie ouverte
à charger un fusil et à m'en servir
même à faisait ces choses là mais ma
tête avaient du mal à suivre
j'ai serré ma main sur son coeur qui bat
et pendant tout ce temps qu'ils étaient
au moins j'ai fait que prier pour lui là
bas j'étais en libérateur des gens
trépignait dans les rues en nous
attendons moi ça me manque parfois
ouais moi aussi
si toi qui dis toujours qu'il faut
épargner tous le moyen de plus faire
marcher dessus c'est d'avoir raté racing
je veux pas que tu travailles pour eux
je travaillerai pas pour eux je
travaillerai pour nombre
je suis partie des femmes au pays pour
découvrir autour de rien n'avait changé
chez pense qu'on a autorisé à faire
l'album était dans le mississippi le
[ __ ] toi tu sors par derrière je me
voyais les choses différemment
et quand son regard est opposée sur moi
je ne sentais plus invisible jeter
vulgaire ni fléau toi peut-être grand
riz et ronnie go pour leur marquer mais
moi je suis pas dupe ferait mieux
d'ouvrir les yeux frangins mais
tellement occupés à penser qu'à toi est
ton domaine que tu vois même pas ta
femme est malheureuse
[Musique]
ils ont travaillé cette terre tout leur
je suis pas habitué à reculer son
adversaire
cette terre qui serait jamais la leur
t'as pas tombé l'été je peux pas rester
ici
ils ont travaillé à en sus et tout ira
bien ils ont su r sans faire saigner se
sont saignés en chromé
ce moment ils font cette surface tu
évolues
qui serait jamais la leur
[Musique]
quand je pense à la ferme je pense à la
boue je rêvais en mars
[Musique]
en plein essor